I got listed.
Tim Pool sent me this thing really next to Richard Spencer as being a far right.
Influence it,
right influence far right was if they call me far right.
Amazing.
I'm left.
They're liars.
I am fucking left.
Did that ball,
you know socialist.
Yeah.
I consider universal basic income.
Have really good idea.
I want free college education could easy.
I would like to spend more in taxes.
If they could fix inner city communities and take these poor neighborhoods and
we spend a fuckload them spend more you fucking real promise.
Promise.
The more money you spend,
it doesn't mean that the problems,
money problems.
That's the price.
And you sign up.
I bet you look coming out of your pores.
You Socialist.
Why don't you leave my country at 6% African?
So watch your fucking mouth,
dude.
No wonder it's so a compassionate compassion is everything.
But I think these people were too compassionate.
This is what the problem is.
They're like,
oh,
you identify as a Wood Elf.
Oh cool.
You're an Elf.
I don't want to,
I didn't.
You know,
whatever your feelings.
And here's the thing,
they're terrified of someone coming after them.
So they try to embrace the more preposterous,
the better.
Yeah.
Like they're having a real hard time now with this woman,
the congressman,
you know,
a who said a bunch of antisemitic shit,
who's going to ties stop.
Right.
And is really shit.
What is it antisemetic has she said anything bad about Jews and general,
the anti Israeli stuff,
which,
which I think you can make a distinction.
I think you should be able to,
I think you should be able to make an intelligent argument that there is a
difference between being not anti Israeli but having problems with their
policies and Jews.
Right.
Cause there are a lot of Jews that are critical of Israel as well.
100%.
Yeah.
So it's,
you know,
but sometimes to silence you and stop the argument.
I don't,
I'm not familiar with what she said exactly,
but I'm not either.
Yeah.
Um,
but,
but yeah,
but go on.
What were you saying about,
about uh,
the problem,
they don't know what to do with her.
They're stuck in this weird spot because they don't like,
here's a perfect example,
where was it?
Um,
was this,
so it was somewhere in Europe where,
um,
these,
this Muslim group was shouting down this LBGT demonstration and the like,
everybody's like,
oh well Jesus,
what do we do here?
We have to protected classes going to war with each other.
And one of them is shouting down.
The other one's saying that,
you know,
homosexuality is forbidden by God,
but then we're supposed to be protective of LBGT.
People were supposed to be open minded and progressive and allowing them.
But,
but then you have these people who are saying that it's their religion,
that they think that this is,
this is wrong.
And this is also a protected class.
You don't want to be Islamophobic.
So what does everyone do it where everyone stands back.
And this is one of the weird moments where people are standing back while Lbgt
people were getting absolutely crucified in the streets,
yelled at with bullhorns,
told her being they're sinners in a blasphemer that actually is part of free
speech,
right?
So sure.
So it's part of being able to organize and express herself,
organize in petition your government that's constitutional.
As long as you don't incite someone to violence,
as long as you don't say,
Hey,
you guys go kill those gay people over there.
I'm not talking about constitutionally,
I mean constitutionally I agree it is free speech.
But what I'm saying is there's no outrage.
There's no commensurate outrage.
Like there would be if say like white nationalists were screaming at these
people.
So,
so here's my issue with the far left or the left or even at,
I forget the right for a second.
I have my own issues with that.
But my,
what the progressive argument,
I always notice that the narrative is very binary.
The narrative is always,
uh,
so for example,
racism is the argument,
right?
So we need to get rid of racism.
I happen to think we could be as identical as penguins and we'd still find
reasons to break into US versus them.
Well,
we'd have an ideological but off.
Of course we did look,
look at the Middle East.
If racism was the ultimate problem,
then you,
the Middle East would be fairly,
would be a fine Sunni's and Shia,
the Ebola new robot.
I mean I can keep going with,
with the be all kinds of people that look at the Dinka and the Nuer of the Sudan
sworn enemies.
They look exactly the same.
So human beings don't need to have different colored skin.
I couldn't agree more.
Yeah.
So so,
so we are tribal and it's fun to break into these US versus them.
I think that the biggest problem is,
is kind of deciding that first of all the Internet has made it very possible for
you to purify your echo chamber.
Yeah,
that's a big problem.
And,
and then you surround yourself with people who think and see the world exactly
like yourself.
And I think we get smarter when we listened to the other side of me.
If you don't agree with them because your ideas aren't working and their ideas
aren't working,
but put your ideas together and maybe somebody gets pregnant with a new idea,
you know the,
the ideas that there's some way that you could stop all division between human
beings.
As long as people are allowed to express themselves,
they live unique and individual lives.
That's never gonna happen.
No,
you're going to have people that come from different parts of the world where
different things are more important.
You're going to have people that come from different economic situations.
It's going to be different.
I mean,
when,
when I say that I'm almost a socialist,
what I mean is like,
look,
there's certain things that we just accept that we need.
Like here's one.
You need a well funded fire department,
right?
Who's,
who's money?
Everybody would pooling all our money into that grind.
Right?
We agree with that.
We agree there's well funded public education.
You have to have that right.
While we barely do that right now,
but we do have that and teachers are getting fucked left and right.
They're getting minimal pay children or going to school in hazardous conditions,
but it's at least there's some money being pumped.
Police officers,
we agree.
So street fixing the streets.
We agree.
We agree on a lot of things,
but then it gets a,
certain things would go,
okay,
well that's where we draw the line.
Well,
why do we draw the line there?
Why do we draw the line,
um,
with when it comes to community upheavals,
like fixing,
fixing communities.
Yeah,
I mean infrastructure like chip,
why did,
why,
why don't we have like,
why don't we,
if we really a team or if the United States really team,
why don't we look at it as a team in terms of equal allocation of resources to
solve conflicts and problems including crime.
We don't,
yeah,
right out of times the problem is isolating the source of the problem.
Right?
So people disagree on what the actual problem is.
I can give you examples.
I mean when,
when we talk about illegal immigration on what to actually do about it,
people are all over the board with it and they'll challenge your solution in
court and there's all kinds of steel nights,
which probably is a good thing.
So things don't get to,
they don't swing too far in either direction.
A universal basic income,
universal healthcare con control.
These are actually fairly complicated issues.
You know,
I don't want spree shooters,
you know,
but when you get down to it and,
and you hear people that are really educated on the subject of guns,
they can get you twisted up in an argument.
If you start talking about gun control because you realize this is a complicated
issue and maybe it's a mental health issue,
maybe it's a thousand issues,
certainly a mental health,
there's a lot of issues with it.
But the ability that someone has to do,
what is it?
Is it only one guy?
More than one person got arrested in New Zealand?
Correct.
Now I think it was just one guy.
They got arrested but only one shoot as far as I know.
So the other ones were planning it out there,
maybe.
Yeah.
No,
I think he was dead.
Yeah.
But,
but my,
my thing is that point is that you have to be ill.
There no other way.
You do have to be mentally ill nor to do that.
Now I want you to think about the fact there's more guns in there are people.
So in this country alone,
there's 300 plus million people.
There's more than 300 million guns,
relatively speaking.
The number of mass shootings is incredibly small in comparison to the amount of
guns and the amount of sick people and how many people are sick who don't become
mass shooter.
Right?
It's a big number.
Yes.
It's very true.
Those are things in a lot of the gun violence,
uh,
that the left talks about.
A lot of those are suicides.
So a lot of it.
Yeah,
a lot of that as suicides,
a lot of it is cops shooting bad guys.
A lot of his people defending themselves.
And then after that you have gang violence.
But so,
so,
but the problem is that when people argue,
they make these things very simplistic and they're not,
you know,
even the,
even identity politics.
I mean,
you know,
straight white males are essentially the enemy.
So the idea would be if we take straight my white males out of the equation,
because this is all power,
right?
It's all talking to Amy Schumer millions.
No,
but I know I'm not.
But this tyrannical hierarchy and stuff as if you took white males and took all
of them out of the equation as if there wouldn't be a new hierarchy.
Yeah.
That's fucking new code.
You know?
It's just the way shit happens.
People,
when you try to make things really equal in a communist society,
the people closest to the government making decisions,
they become the new elite.
So you're not going to fucking know,
avoid that shit.
Yeah.